right nice it's really important me to
see as much as possible I would try this
omelette here display with a Carol
deputy table the KE on this and I'm
gonna go after that for the honey pecan
salmon okay and then good old-fashioned
fish and chips oh yeah thanks
excellent you just have been staring at
me
nice um big muscle head meatball it's
not my crab meat how do you want anybody
to get the misconception not official
here's a pretty bold statement thank you
my darling
Wow the size of that that's a lot of
crap and you haven't told me about decay
yet oh he said he wanted everybody to
know that it wasn't real kravitz
artificial crap so he spelled it with a
k' so there was no misconception
so it's fake crab meat in a seafood
restaurant on the water holy crap
brother takes this does go straight to
the trash table didn't go over well he
doesn't like the crab in there i-i've
never that was already here I didn't buy
that stuff I don't want to use frozen
fish it's not product that I'm
absolutely overly proud of but at the
same point I'm held accountable for all
the inventory that the owners have paid
for the food so far why we serving fake
crab in our own way
I don't get it that you're the general
manager why are you off I give the
choice have you been drinking no the
crab was shocking embarrassing and fake
it tastes disgusting have you tasted
that crap no I'm extremely allergic to
crab shrimp so I can't mean there's no
crab in there
I understand it's my fish oh my gosh
I'll let you finish early
[Music]
general manager my ass and we live he
things that actually allowed him to do
that poor letting him serve those types
of a ration let's take them AJ is the
general manager he's supposed to oversee
the food and now I'm hoping and praying
that Gordon says AJ's the one that's
bleeding this business okay
suddenly the best-looking thing I've
seen some really rubbery is a frozen the
fish I believe it's wrong okay
when you take it by to that card it's
almost like you've got a breaded condom
in your mouth he said it was rubbery too
greasy
and just that it tasted like a frozen
Cod and obviously hit it right on the
buttons this is the same recipe that
we've used here forever so I'm for
change I want to change good wow this
one is the semolina dad
thank you three I think just so sweet
the dressing is like honey that's so
much of it absolutely disgusting quite
possibly one of the worst salmon dishes
I've ever eaten
it's a pretty successful opinion though
tower of seafood a big big club what's
in there
this is a layer of shrimp salad the
later Vaughn crab cakes bacon and
lettuce and tomato thank you
how to start easy sandwich this wire I
mean honestly it's cautionary death I
[Music]
surrender to break it down deconstructed
Wow the crab delicious
it's a very pleasant surprise let me
tell you
it's nice layer of crap
and then he's stone-cold shrimp
underneath manda works this bit here I
mean then the text either week-old you
might got their ghastly to the fridge
just have a word after this it's all
about sex
he almost takes by the tainted yeah just
a mess
I'll leave that one done so the shrimp
tastes like that the head like a weird
aftertaste her like I'm Lucy's play
really the refrigerator
he's gonna taste like their old
a lot of the menu items are crap
it's Denise's recipes it's the way she
wants it done I don't understand this is
perfect
Denise never think she's wrong this is
burger stand that's her biggest downfall
[Music]
it's good enough
are we happy with this I'm taking a
sleaze stick it Denise does what Denise
wants to do and she won't listen to me
she won't listen to anyone else it's
aggravating english-style fish and chips
well English style for me macro House
cut fries from fresh potatoes and what
kind of fish is it cod fish cod fish
okay well simply use everything just
greasy no okay great thank you thank you
sighs the nightosphere this trans fat
to the batter soggy does even stick to
the fish
stressful mache when it's dry let's just
drive well the whole batter just sort of
almost like peels away from it those
fries or shame was just so soggy with my
fingers yeah we have 50 tips and the
tastiest thing on the plate is the
tartar sauce it's a big disappointment I
love fish and chips shame the cooks are
doing the best that they can with the
way they've been told to do things so
it's nice this fall over all greasy fish
fry the batter is just falling off of it
and I said the fries they were much
changed really
that's weird when he squeezed it and all
this like grease all over him french
fries you know you get some potatoes
that are one way and potatoes are
another way and they're having a problem
with a consistency of the potato I mean
it's just making me crazy
first name is Catalina Catalina place me
you're the I'm one of the owners latch
chest
okay I have a partner Marcelo is a man
what we used to be married we've been
separated for two years you used to be
married to my partner oh Jesus
this is like water and oil we just don't
mix it's just like conflict all the time
well it's all about the food I'll look
through the menu nice to meet you oh my
god real interesting bit cool yeah this
is like a song how are you sir yeah how
are you yeah rowdy thank you let's start
off with chicken classic soup let's go
for the pescado Mona or the Italia yeah
absolutely
I really believe to check rice you're
gonna gonna like the food I think that
97 percent of my food will be great
thank you very much
and that's very fast very fast indeed
let's hope it's good
[Music]
that would be a pain in the ass because
I the superficial it's co hot it's cold
let me get that for you okay absolutely
he would like a hot soup not cold will
say that Ramsay said what happened with
the school I have a thermometer here
boiling hot you wanna check to me it
wasn't boiling up and now it's boiling
hot this varies but when we're know if
it was before you guys send something
out please check double check triple
check yes yes listen go to the bar
I'm sorry about that my just when I went
to taste these these are salty I mean
you'd need six mojitos before you start
eating 6 spoons of that mate they're
disgusting excuse me let me take this
back shame the basics I'll try that
means
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
god there's definitely definitely a lack
of harmony in the kitchen 1 DS 1 light
light now there's gonna be a complete
disaster
[Music]
how you doing yeah fine
Angie I'll find can I get you anything
else while you wait no no wait for the
clap yeah okay thank you
all right thank you very much Wow I know
I can't believe it
it beats the basing of us I hope you
enjoy cuz it's actually my favorite dish
thank you delicious well yeah the fish
is not cooked
oh it's really not that is a shame I'm
gonna bring it back that's a very big
mistake on behalf of the kitchen okay
possible not cooked raw fish wrong with
you guys is wrong cook
I put the tester that the open this is
this mannequins wrong what's wrong
excuse me
Santa Catalina please Chris hello Canada
pressure heat should not be on the
kitchen at all listen and no playing
around right now
I don't worry about we're gonna know
this put your phone away
are you all ready
oh yes let's start off with lobster
bisque okay sir I'll get for the
marinara he's one of the house
specialties wonderful another leech the
people akari's worth chicken and garlic
sauce on the bone love it beginning i
walked in i thought was a phenol now i'm
is finally got me back okay brilliant
I hope who's doing everything yeah I
can't wait what makes you got nothing to
do with this order
iein hang on my boys the drive but I'm
so confident overseeing my guys that I
got nothing to worry about these guys
been by my side 15 years now go go go go
let's see what he thinks
they just looks disgusting
my queen is always a scream yes you're a
queen like it just looks like loves was
dead before they killed him they're from
a lot of fun to tank you want to take a
look okay see that no I think they're
just sleeping you must be dead we keep a
good eye on this they keep a good eye on
them surely not bass parts of dirt a
dead Lobster
now he's gone okay
what I'm concerned about is everything
else in there they've been feeding off
that lobster yes and they become full of
bacteria look that is extremely
unacceptable dangerous people could get
extremely sick with that I'll get rid of
this right now okay please love you bye
[Music]
don't smell that lobsters fresh even
though it died it's good
[Music]